ever since the first case of Ebola
surfaced in the United States the
Centers for Disease Control has made one
mistake after another I mean it's been
kind of absurd it all culminated last
week when the CDC allowed an Ebola
patient to fly on a commercial jet while
another suspected Ebola carrier was
allowed to go on a Carnival cruise yes
anyway today the CDC announced strict
new protocols especially for patient
travel and to put everyone at ease right
now at this moment the CDC is doing a
live run-through of how they would
transfer an Ebola patient from Dallas to
the CDC Hospital in Atlanta now we have
a helicopter standing by to watch this
drill it's pretty exciting let's take a
look first the CDC is escorting the
patient out of the hospital and putting
him on the Dallas m12 bus line which is
then taking the patient to the Dallas
Amtrak station now the CDC is putting
the patient on an overbooked train to
st. Louis once in st. Louis the patients
hopping on a casino riverboat which is
having a swingers only cruise of the
Mississippi River
then the CDC is stopping the transfer in
davenport for a visit to the Iowa State
Fair where the same spoon for every one
Chili Cook Off the state
and the International coughing contest
now the CDC has placed the patient in a
truck with a hundred illegal immigrants
while being smuggled to Atlanta Oh looks
like the truck is broken down don't
worry the CDC is on it they have shown
the patient into the center of a human
centipede
[Music]
[Applause]
you